Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
August 27th,
2012 how's it going?
I'm actually recording this Sunday night cause I got a bunch of Shit to do
tomorrow and I got this,
I got this burst of energy on a Sunday and I was like,
you know what?
I'm going to,
I'm going to take care of all the fucking shit that I'm going to hate to have to
do tomorrow morning.
You know,
going to pay the bills,
going to go down to fucking windshields and go get a pretzel.
You don't give a fuck.
Right?
Is any,
who the fuck eats there by the way?
What is windshields?
Do they make hot dogs?
They just make that shit ass fucking food.
That fat pasty white people just can't get enough of,
you know,
that's how you fucking do it.
All these,
all these athletes taking the roids,
you don't need that.
You go down to the food court,
Orange Julius,
you go to that place that doesn't like the queers that makes the chicken
sandwiches.
Right.
You get some fries from them.
I love it.
That's part of,
you guys have seen that that chick filet,
they don't like gay people.
Chick filet.
We don't like the gay.
If you're straight,
he can eat our fucking burger.
A few Aa,
you know?
Then you,
I think you're getting enough meat in your life,
buddy.
The fuck year are we living in and
more importantly,
how much fucking money you make and sell and chicken that you can get rid of
that portion,
that amount of people in the population.
You know,
why the fuck he act like you Mcdonald's Chick-Filet you're not.
You know you're not even Popeye's.
Forget about KFC.
The fuck in Babe Ruth,
Michael Jordan of feeding people unhealthy chicken.
You know that shit.
God Damn God.
That's your fucking led Zeppelin right there.
The chicken industry right there.
That old fucking plantation owner,
if that slave,
that's how much.
That's how fucking good they are.
Cooking chicken.
They have a goddamn looks like a fucking slave owner straight out of that movie
roots as their,
their mascot or their spokesperson.
You know what I mean?
Lease Wendy's has that nonthreatening sort of fucking fat white guy.
You know,
who looks like he loves his wife,
but probably,
you know,
steals from the company.
If he's in the accounting division,
doesn't,
he actually does.
Look,
he,
that guy and the guy from Wendy's does not look honest.
100% honest.
He looks like a real swell guy who one day the,
the feds would show up in a,
raid his house and grab his hard drive,
and then he'd come out weeping and his family would be all stunned at the double
life that they weren't aware that he was leading.
It doesn't even look like that.
You just see his stupid glasses fogging up,
you know?
And then of course gets convicted,
right?
They go through all the bullshit.
Nancy grace with their fucking angry Hellboy head would be sitting there,
you know,
the fucking female Jim Rome,
right?
Getting all fucking pissed off with flames going behind her.
And then what,
what happened?
Eight months later,
Bryant Gumbel would show up.
Oh,
maybe you'd send that fucking vampire,
uh,
grandpa monster there,
frank to Ford.
And they would go and interview the guy,
right?
The Wendy's guy.
And he'd be sitting there and his fucking jumpsuit,
you know,
like if there's pudgy hands just ringing them together and they'd just be like,
where did it all go wrong?
I lead,
I lead you.
You had the think at some point you were gunna get caught,
don't ya?
I mean,
what were you thinking?
And then you just be like,
Eh,
okay.
I don't what I was thinking.
Tik Tik Tik Tik Tik Tik Tik Tik Tik tonight on 60 minutes,
that fest fuck from Wendy's,
who he thought was an honest guy.
Guess now he's a piece of shit.
Does that make you feel better about your life?
You fucking cunt.
Well,
why don't you go walking in the mirror and rather than just fucking brush your
teeth,
you look into it and really think about some of the shit that you've done.
You know?
And maybe if you fucking had some talent in life,
you could have been a piece of shit at that level.
We're,
it'd be worthy of telling your piece of shit stories on 60 minutes or some other
investigative news program.
Bill,
where the fuck you going with this?
I'll tell you where I'm going with this.
Lance Armstrong one that God damn bike by grace,
he did it seven times in a fucking row.
All right,
and now you're telling me he didn't.
Yeah,
he did
are fucking roided up guy beat your roid it up guys seven fucking times in a row
and I don't care how you slice it,
how you dice it,
whatever the fuck you do.
Go Fuck Yourself.
They were all dope and therefore it's an even playing field.
It's like the 2004 fucking Boston Red Sox when they beat the Yankees are roided
up guys beat your wrote it up guys.
That's level.
That's a level playing field.
Yeah,
I can't fucking believe those constantly just kept coming at him.
It common at and then finally everybody fucking cracked.
You know,
bunch of God damn pussies,
all lining up to fucking rat the guy out.
Isn't the,
is there any like,
okay.
You know,
wasn't half the fun when you were growing up.
When the teacher knew you did something but couldn't fucking prove it and knew
that you knew who the fuck did it.
He just sat there and you wouldn't fucking say shit and you got to watch this
person in power be defeated.
You know what the fuck are they going to duty?
Okay,
why did these other bike ride and jackass is all crumble?
What were they threatening you with?
I don't fucking get it.
Okay,
let me,
let me ask you this.
How to fuck is Lance Armstrong's cheating?
But these old roid it up,
guys.
You see at night the nighttime,
that's synergetics.
They're not cheating.
They're on fucking HGH.
They didn't earn their six pack of them.
None of this shits getting taken away.
Go Fuck Yourself,
all right.
He won the thing.
He wanted seven times in a fucking role.
I don't,
I don't give a shit.
Barry bonds
hit the most fucking whole runs of all time.
All right.
And he did it.
He just say he did it during the roid error.
That's all we're all going to be on him.
You know it's going to happen.
No one wants to have a chicken neck.
No one wants you to have your fucking tits that you never had before.
Now sliding into your fucking stomach,
your stomach's just a slit.
You know,
that's how fat you get as you get older,
when you're fucking naval looks like a fucking ass crack is somebody sleeping on
a couch on its side,
right all the way down to the old fucking ball bag.
You don't want that.
You want to be shredded.
Okay.
And it's already starting old people are taking the fucking thanks for what?
Cause they're trying to make division one football.
No,
cause they want to look good.
Okay.
And how do we know how to give it to these people?
Because they heroes.
Okay.
Like fucking Lance Armstrong all the way back to Lao Lau.
Zeto they put this shit in their fucking bodies and you know those fucking cops
out there and silicone valley,
they got to watch what happened.
Slowly make improvements.
I'm telling you,
within 15 years,
I guaran fucking tee you.
There's going to be kids sprinkling h g h onto their fucking corn flakes.
Wondering why Lance Armstrong wasn't allowed to say that he won that fucking
bike race seven years in a row.
I got fucking news for you.
If you want to see people not on Roids,
try and ride a bicycle up a fucking mountain,
okay?
For six fucking weeks in a row,
whatever the hell it is.
You want to see them do that all natural,
that's going to be the most boring shit you've ever seen in your life.
You might as well watch me do it at that point,
my fucking head turning all red wheeze and just looking at the mountain.
All right?
It's some superhero shit.
Okay?
There's no fucking Santa Claus.
It's over.
All right.
Do you think this shit's going to end?
It's not going to end.
We're going to move on to bionic people next.
They're literally going to take out the bottom of people's legs below the
fucking kneecap and they're going to put a Strutton.
They're just like,
they do want a car,
you know,
and then white people going
to be Duncan and then black people will be like,
dude,
what the fuck?
You know,
give me some bionic legs and you have a fucking Michael Jordan with bionic legs.
Yeah.
I'm telling you by 2030 the Goddamn back board and the NBA is going to be up
where all those Celtics championship banners are.
Okay.
That's my theory.
Give me a fucking break.
I was really rooting for that guy.
Not that I like Cheetos.
It's you can't ride a bike 60 miles an hour up and down a fucking mount without
being on.
So why is everybody acting like this is a surprise?
And then he's just see these fucking Douche bag people in the media,
right?
They all,
they all can't fucking wait to jump all over Lance Armstrong's why?
Because they sucked in gym class and you know,
you know the deal in high school,
you don't get any pussy cause you got an a in creative writing.
All right?
And then these fucking little smarty kids,
they see these meathead athletes walking around with their fucking abs in that
pex going,
ow,
fucking gimme the ball.
Right?
And they just sit there going,
why is she sucking the Dick?
That fucking moron.
And it just,
it bugs him
and they can't wait.
They can't wait for the day for one,
one of them gets caught doing something for them to be fat and coming back to
the reunion,
you know?
And they can be,
they're like,
oh,
I fucking write for this paper,
Huh?
And then they go over to that cheerleader used to be good,
now faces all fucking shiny with the botox,
but he's still fucking grabs her by a fucking hair at this point.
Right.
You know,
he's got that,
you know that you're not an old lady,
but you're not a young lady here.
You know,
where it starts to be extremely flammable after all the years of highlight.
And it's like a fucking goddamn birds nest,
you know,
sort of a dude's hair cut at that point.
But they added some sort of little flip to it,
you know?
So it's still technically a feminine haircut and you're just fucking jamming it
down towards your slacks,
right?
So this is what this Douche had to say.
This is what this,
oh,
by the way,
I forgot to say this at the top of the podcast.
This podcast is brought to you.
Today's show is brought to you by audible.
Please visit audible.com/bill for your free audio book download.
Huh?
Why would you want to read with someone can read it for you?
Why would you want to ride a bike up a damn mountain without having roids
injected into you?
I don't want to do that.
There's a reason why people don't ride a bike to work when they live on the
other side of a fucking mountain.
All right?
Cause it hurts your legs.
You need something beyond vitamins.
How fucking exciting is the Tour de France?
Fucking cool.
I love it.
I don't care that they're on roids.
Give them more fucking Roy.
Make them go faster.
One go fast.
I'll go fast.
They can go fast.
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
All right,
so this is what?
This fucking Douche bag rope.
He's sitting there,
um,
blah,
blah.
He goes,
it's most of basically lance tapped out.
All right.
He said,
I refuse to participate.
If he saw this whole like basically it would seem that old show,
this is your life.
It was just like the game show where everybody ever knew it was going to come
walking out and rather than me and Lego rubber I Todd Yada ride at to grow.
It's not going to be that.
It's going to be a bunch of old people got him in his buttocks and he didn't
want to deal with that,
which I can't blame them.
Um,
but I got to admit they were going after him the way they were going after
Michael Jackson.
You know,
when I said he was fucking touching kids,
and I actually read an article one time is some fucking some Guy Rodney,
he was sitting there and actually watch the trial as opposed to me who just kind
of walk by TV's in the airport and looked at Michael's weird nose and we're
like,
yeah,
he did it right.
This guy actually was at the trial and he said he couldn't believe that it
actually went to trial.
That's how fucking week the case was.
You know,
that being said,
I wouldn't leave a fucking bull frog with that maniac toward his fucking dad did
to him.
But that's a whole different story.
It's probably a bad point.
That point actually probably just weakened my fucking argument here.
Anyways,
this is what,
this fucking Douche who never got picked in gym class rope.
Okay.
He's saying,
uh,
at this point he did okay.
And all his friends are going to come out and basically say that he did do it.
You know,
can you stop yelling at me now?
Fucking pussies.
Um,
he goes at,
so anyways,
Armstrong show what the fuck was going to happen.
So it's,
the guy writes at this point,
at that point,
he did what he'd never done before.
He gave up the pug nation texts and continue to proclaim his innocence.
But when the time came for him to hear his friends and associates incriminate
him and try to refute their accusations,
I'm Sachsen said it just wasn't worth the trouble.
All right.
Uh,
he says are refused and Armstrong said,
I refuse to participate in the process.
That is so one sided and unfair.
Um,
attempting a whatever you send instead,
he's going to focus on serving people and families affected by cancer attempting
to be the fittest 40 year old on the planet.
I love that.
The fact that he did roid somehow negates the fact that he came back from
basically you're going to die level cancer and had to leave one ball on a table.
You know what I mean?
I having the fact that he could even sit on a fucking bicycle seat ever again.
To me it's pretty fucking amazing.
You know,
I walk up my fucking stairs and,
and I'm winded.
Sending waste the results means he'll be stripped of every metal and title he
won going back to August,
1998.
The exact fucking thing that this nerd writer wants,
take away all these shiny stuff that I don't know how to win,
um,
is extraordinary career will be vaporized from the record books.
The apparently won't even be allowed to compete and sanction triathlons.
His recent,
uh,
interest.
Um,
Blahblahblahblahblah and then he adds a shit.
Here he goes.
His most devoted admirers may take his word that he was being railroaded by a
vindictive body using unfair tactics,
but really what else could a guilty person say in the face of so much evidence?
What evidence that people were going to say he did it?
I don't get how,
first of all,
it's what's,
what the fuck I don't get,
they had a hard on for this guy when he was winning.
You know,
you should have caught him then.
One does the statute of limitations run out on the ship?
New evidence suggests.
What?
Did you just find a video of the guy fucking injecting them?
I don't know.
Anyways,
the agency also found that blood tests from 2009 indicated he was doping.
None of that.
This is all fucking hearsay at this point.
Right.
Um,
his most devoted admirers may take his word that he was being railroaded by
vindictive body using unfair tactics,
but really what else would it go to Bubba?
The story is a particular shame because Armstrong who survived the 1996 bought
with statistics,
testicular cancer that had spread to his abdomen and lungs was such an
inspiration to so many cancer victims.
He used his fame to found live strong,
a foundation that provides support to victims of the disease.
So what are you telling me now that people who have cancer are now looking at
this guy as if he's still not like a fucking hero?
The guy came back from ball cancer that had spread to his abdomen and his lungs
and won a fucking the best bike race,
the hardest bike race on the planet.
He wanted seven years and a fucking row and Bang Shell Sheryl Crow.
Right?
You're telling me this guy's that's still a hero.
Let me ask you this person who wrote this fucking article.
Huh?
Let me ask you this.
What about you?
What have you ever fucking one that you can sit here and judge a guy like this
didn't even fucking go to trial.
And you can sit here and talk about this fucking guy like that.
How?
What the fuck did you ever done?
Huh?
Everyone of your are.
You never cheated on any your articles.
You never cheated on your wife.
You never cheated on your taxes.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Why is this bothering me so much?
I don't,
I don't even fucking know wides bugging me.
You know
at,
you know what it is.
If everybody else in the top 20 is doing shit,
they all got caught too.
All right
then.
It's a fucking level playing field.
He's so much fucking better than those other guys.
Not only did he win the race,
you still couldn't even catch them.
You couldn't catch him on a bike or in the fucking lab.
All those other Bozos who just sitting there staring at his ass in the entire
fucking race,
they all got caught,
right?
Whatever.
I'm trying
all,
there you go.
18 fucking minutes ranting and raving about a fucking bike race.
All right.
He voice everybody.
Would it be great if you could start a business in your cubicle without your
boss knowing about it?
You know?
Well,
how could I do that belt?
Well with he voice.
Um,
basically your mobile phone,
okay.
It becomes like you,
you,
you can,
I don't know,
when I read the copy,
I can't even explain this thing.
It's so mind blowing to an old guy like me.
It's basically,
you know,
your cell phone,
how you have,
you have one phone number and it rings.
And in order to get that phone to ring,
people have to know that number.
Would it be great if you could have like,
I dunno,
five,
10 other numbers and that phone would ring and no one knew your real number.
Wouldn't that be awesome?
Be a great way to start a business.
What if they actually had professional voiceover actors that when you didn't
pick up the phone,
it sounded like you had some sexy double o seven secretary and you were in this
the coolest office ever yet it was just your cell phone.
Huh?
Let me tell you this,
one of the great features of each voice is everything I just said.
And it has music on hold.
Do they're creating this entire virtual office,
virtual phone numbers,
all of it.
It doesn't even exist,
man.
This is the greatest thing ever.
Uh,
makes your business seem even more professionals,
ie voice.
We'll treat your clients and customers to music on hold.
You could even set up an e voice to run promotional advertisements for your
company while people are on hold instead of music.
All of this lending to your credibility as this wheeler and dealer sitting there
smoking a stokey.
Uh,
Eva also has the call recording feature,
which is perfect for any doctor,
lawyer,
real estate agents,
hiring managers or any other professional,
uh,
discussing contracts,
easy to use as you just press star two to start and start to,
to stop.
That's it.
Perfect.
If you're driving and can't write something important down eve voice makes your
life easier and seem more professional for your free six month trial,
go to www dot [inaudible] dot com slash bill burr www dot [inaudible] dot com
slash bill burr or go to the banner ad on my podcast page at [inaudible] dot com
we actually had a listener,
a raving about it,
starting his own business on,
on Twitter.
Sent me a great,
uh,
a great tweet about it.
I should,
I should really retweet that.
But the people at a voice we're doing backflips,
they were so excited that somebody actually used it and,
and had the results that they claim.
So they go,
if you're trying to start your own business,
all right,
back to the podcast.
What else happened?
Oh,
the red sox.
The Red Sox had a fire sale.
I love it.
I got to tell you this.
I absolutely love it.
Okay.
And I'm just equating the red sox basically to van Halen.
This is basically what happened.
We had David Lee Roth,
everything was great.
2004 maybe 2007 after we won the second one.
That's like
2004 to 2007 that was like van Halen one all the way to 1984 alright.
And then what happened?
Tito left,
David Lee left and now we got Sammy Hagar.
Now we just dumped all the players.
So that's to me is like Sammy Hagar and Michael Anthony art in the band anymore.
And now we got Gary Showrun.
Now Gary,
Sharon's in,
I don't know what to tell you.
All I can tell you is this is what I love about this.
What I love about my own team,
just shitting the bed the way that they do is I love the empty seats.
Okay?
I love it.
I love seeing all the bandwagon go home like the bandwagon pussies that I knew
you were.
You weren't there when we sucked.
You showed up when we started getting good and you wrote it out like all those
fucking cunts who fill up the stadium now every time the Patriots play a game,
where the fuck were you back when we had that shitty stadium with the aluminum
seats?
Where were ya?
Huh?
He would know where he was sitting at all drinking hot cocoa with your fucking
slippers on.
You know,
and I know a lot of people right now are probably going to be going,
yeah,
good flow.
Good boy.
Stupid fucking shit.
Fuck,
fuck you all right.
Look at your own God damn state and you want to see what your fan base is.
If you really want to see the true fan base of your team,
go to a game when they suck on any level.
Hockey,
basketball,
baseball,
football,
rugby,
fucking tidily wakes,
whatever it is.
When your team sucks and the people that go,
those are the die hards.
I can't believe this already.
MPC to Fenway park,
up to everything that that team's done for that city.
Okay.
What were only 11 months in?
They've had an 11 month bad run.
I was back there in Boston.
All these fucking people crying and pissing and moaning,
bunch of fucking babies.
He went,
the greatest thing about the bandwagon people leaving is I think it ups the
chance of that stupid song to be discontinued during the seventh inning stretch.
Is there any way we can sell that to the Dodgers too?
Is there any way we could just get rid of that?
Sweet care will lie.
Bob,
uh,
you know,
if I was a dictator and I was looking to trim down the population,
I would play that song in,
in the public square with the banner of my face,
you know,
all around it.
And I would play that.
And whoever's sang along that would be at the black van would show up to your
fucking house and you would be,
you would be a,
you would be automatically signed up for my re educational program,
which basically involves your skull being used as a fucking lamp post.
I'm sorry.
That's doesn't it makes it a lamp shade.
Maybe.
I don't know what the fuck that's,
what am I trying to say?
A footstool.
There you go.
Um,
so I'm actually excited.
I think it's a great fucking thing.
I think it's great for the Red Sox,
Yankees rivalry.
You know,
red sox suck so much that they now,
now they don't have to fucking amp it up.
That deck,
the kind of face each other and then that can just,
you know,
back off for a little bit and then maybe in a couple of years it gets good
again.
You know,
as opposed to be like they're meeting again 27 times this year to 100 million
versus 180 who gives a fuck?
Dover.
So I want to thank the red sox for fucking back to like all the way from 1999
on,
I haven't had a fucking problem with you guys.
Spent fucking an absolute joy to watch you play.
All right.
It's been fucking great.
And now you're going through the rough times,
eh?
You know,
I'm still going to watch.
I can't fucking wait to watch whatever the fuck his left to this tape play in
September.
You know,
I don't know.
Why
can you,
can you people in Boston do me a favor.
Can you guys can,
can we start a movement to start bullying that fucking song during the seventh
inning stretch?
Can somebody start a website?
Could somebody,
okay,
I'm late in the match.
Somebody go get the gas.
Let's just,
let's just go for a total clean slate here.
All right.
It's starting over again.
For some reason,
Bobby,
this sticking with Bobby Vee,
I don't know why.
If for some reason the more he goes out and yells at Umpires,
I'm actually starting to like the guy.
Um,
all right,
so he's on hold,
but can we,
can we just get rid of that fucking song?
You know,
one of the great things I used to tease Yankee fans about was the fact that they
sang [inaudible] during the seventh inning stretch.
Okay.
I never understood why they did it.
The,
the
legendary franchise that it is.
I just,
you sitting in this village people song and everybody in the stands is going,
Whoa,
your MCA,
a Douche bags are Douche bags are not real Yankee fence.
They're not doing it.
They're fucking sitting there,
you know,
I don't know what they're doing.
Pulling their hat down over their eyes.
It's fucking embarrassing.
It's embarrassing.
Okay.
But that's not my fucking problem.
Can we please,
as a red sox fan who started watching back when they actually had red hats,
that clown hat that they wore in the 70s,
first game I went to was in [inaudible] 78 the summer of 78,
by the way.
Um,
what was it?
70 yeah,
78.
Yeah.
Can we please,
let's start with the song.
Let's get rid of the song.
This will be like a fan fire sale.
We'll get,
we'll start with the song and then next will be that fucking mascot.
Okay.
And uh,
and I don't know where to go from there cause I don't live there anymore.
Those two fucking things annoy the shit out of me.
Get that struggling actor out of that fucking suit.
Okay.
I hate mascots.
I've said this before.
I hate when you talk to them when there's no kids around and they still won't
say anything
and you're like,
hey,
what's going on?
And they do that fucking,
you know,
I smoke crystal meth.
Fucking psycho.
Nod at you.
You know,
did salting,
I know you're in there.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
this is such a weird fucking podcast so far.
Um,
I'm just going to go off on shit this week and then I'm just going to read
advertising.
How does that work for you guys?
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
Legal.
Zoom.
Would you like to get incorporated?
Would you like to write out a will?
Would you like to,
to copyrights something that you invented and you don't want some big
corporation to steal it from you.
You don't want your eggs to start having the aftertaste of almonds.
Would you like to avoid that?
All right.
Legal zoom.com uh,
you've probably heard about legal zoom.
If you're on youtube,
they have all kinds of ads on there,
but now I am telling you about them.
So you got to check these guys out because a,
they're great.
All right?
If you've been waiting for the perfect time to start your own business,
it's right now.
It's time to get out of the cubicle.
Okay?
Incorporate Your Business or form an llc@legalzoom.com starting at just 99
bucks.
I paid 1500 I went to SAP route.
You can do it yourself for 99 bucks.
And if you have a family,
guess what?
You need to make sure that they're protected.
You can protect your family and assets with the legal zoom will for just 69
bucks.
99 bucks.
You were incorporated.
69 bucks.
Everyone you love is taken care of is protected.
You know,
you still had a 200 bucks.
All right?
Go down to those.
Get yourself a pair of loafers.
And the past 12 years they ever feel good.
Those Aldo shoes,
how,
how many days do you have to go get the blisters before you ever broke those in?
Um,
in the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used legal zoom for LLCs.
Wills,
trusts,
trademarks,
and more.
They save hundreds,
even thousands of dollars versus going the traditional lawyer route,
uh,
lawyer route,
um,
legal zooms online process guide.
You step by step step and you get a total customer support.
It couldn't be much easier.
They even have an attorney to help you if you need to get through any of their
legal stuff.
Um,
Start Your Business and protect your family today@legalzoom.com.
You also get a special discount from listening to this podcast.
Make sure you enter bur bur are in the referral box at the checkout for more
savings.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm and self help services are provided at your
discretion,
your direction.
Sorry.
All right,
so if you get confused,
don't just sit there and wait for a lawyer to help you out.
You call them up and they're going to help you.
Okay.
There you go.
Back to the podcast.
All right.
So,
okay.
See my dog.
My dog is so adorable.
Just laying there sleeping.
You want to hear us?
She sounds when she's sleeping.
You know what?
I'm not gonna cause I'm a put it the microphone up to her nose and all it's
gonna do is gonna wake her up and you guys are not going to see how adorable she
is because this is not a visual medium in case you haven't noticed.
So I'm really gonna do it was just wake her up.
Um,
anyways,
I've been off this whole week.
I'm off next week and then it's fucking on.
I'm torn like a Goddamn band,
speaking of which,
I saw truth and salvage company at the troubadour on a Friday night.
And uh,
if you get a chance to see those guys live,
if you sick of auto tune and a bunch of people acting like this singing but then
not singing because they got to do a bunch of dance steps.
If you would just like to see a band of talented musicians,
everybody in the band can sing their asses off.
It's
okay.
It's everything that's great about music.
Um,
first of all,
I never been to the troubadour and I always heard about that.
Obviously being a guns and roses fan.
So before I went over there,
AH,
look it up on um,
on,
on Wikipedia,
I will try to give you a link or something like that for it.
Um,
but just the amount of people that started out there.
Yeah.
You know,
it just,
it just was mind blowing.
All those singer songwriter people that were out in La and lived in Laurel
Canyon,
the Joni Mitchell's a James Taylor is all the way through.
Right through to,
who else did they have there?
I can't remember.
It was just a WHO's who of everybody.
And then guns and roses of course perform there.
Back when Axel had like two tattoos,
they got all the pictures on the wall.
So I was psyched to go there.
I thought was gonna be this huge place.
It only held like maybe 350 people really intimate setting.
And I went down there and they absolutely smashed it.
And,
uh,
they
were actually out here recording a new album,
truth and salvage company.
Check them out if you like real music.
All right?
And that wasn't a paid advertisement that came from the fucking hot.
All right,
here we go.
So anyways,
I am on the road traveling like a band.
All right.
Not this pussy comedy shit where it's one week.
And then I sit at home staring at my toes and then maybe I'll do another two
days.
This is hardcore.
I am traveling,
I believe for the next fucking six weeks.
Maybe every weekend I'm working.
All right.
Uh,
here we go.
Orlando Improv.
September 7th,
eighth and ninth.
You know,
it was gonna try to go to a gator's game.
Florida gators,
right.
Drive up and go to game course to fucking not playing sons of bitches.
Um,
is there anything else near there?
The Seminoles,
what are the fuck do they play?
I got to see some Florida College football when I'm there.
I'm in Orlando.
If you can recommend something,
let me know.
bill@billbird.com.
Uh,
all right.
Comedy Zone,
Charlotte,
North Carolina,
September 13th 14th and 15th and then my triumphant return.
I love saying that I just coming back to New York,
but I call it my triumphant return is if I went off and conquered something,
I'm actually,
this is the rescheduled date,
the Caroline's date,
September 20th 21st 22nd and 23rd I will be working with the one and only teen
idols sensation from the opiate Anthony Radio program.
Joey roses,
Joe Derosa will be,
they're loaning his headlining services okay.
To to be a feature act.
Something he doesn't do.
He's just doing it for a pal.
Something he's way beyond this.
Guys sold millions of records.
Everybody,
millions of Joey Rose's fans can not be wrong.
He's going to be in the feature act and a opening is a one of my new favorite
comics out there as this kid Sean patent.
He's fucking awesome.
So that's going to be a great show.
All right.
And then the week after that,
I'm going to be at the comedy zone in Jacksonville,
Florida.
Okay.
How about a little pause here in a round of applause for the amount of white
trash people I am going to be serving and dancing for in fucking September or
Lando Florida.
Who goes there?
Unless you going to Disney world,
nobody.
Maybe if you're a whore and you want to blow tiger woods,
I don't know,
right?
Comedy Zone,
Charlotte,
North Carolina,
and then after that I'm in fucking,
two weeks later,
I'm in Jacksonville,
Florida.
Okay?
Am I fucking,
am I doing stand up or am I are my got a reoccurring role on eastbound and down?
Okay?
You tell me this should be a jet ski at the end of this fucking tour.
It's all I'm saying after that,
I go to go bananas in Cincinnati,
Ohio.
All right?
You want it that Cincinnati is one of those cities that even people in
Cincinnati don't go to the leaf.
It's one of those cities,
right?
At five o'clock everybody leaves Zombie fucking town.
Just like Cleveland,
just like Buffalo,
just like all of those fucking rust belt,
God damn towns.
People just leave,
okay?
And I'm sitting there walking down the street.
It's scary,
but I'm going to be there at gold bananas.
Then after that I go to fucking Sydney,
Australia.
Hopefully I go to Sydney,
Australia,
the fucking breaking my balls with all the shit they want me to give him.
So,
um,
I actually set this tore up because I thought my special was going to be coming
out October 1st.
But the people at Netflix,
we're so damn excited,
there's such great people.
They're like,
Bill,
why don't we put it out now?
What are we waiting for?
I said,
okay.
Right.
So now I've got all these fucking back to back dates to put together my new
hour.
Um,
so please come down,
say hello.
Laugh at a couple of jokes too for one Joey roses telling you what have you and
what in his final engagement is a feature act.
Um,
all right,
what else do we got here?
If did I tell you guys?
I'm trying to learn how to make homemade pizza.
How bad do I need to just have a fucking kid already?
How many more hobbies can I start?
Oh,
look who's up.
It's Cleo.
Give me a buddy.
Come here.
Come over here,
come over here.
You know,
all fucking day long.
Even coming over here being all needy and the one time I call you when the
Goddamn microphones on you won't come over right once.
I know we always use this reference,
but it's like that God damn frog right member was singing for that construction
worker and that cartoon.
Hello my baby.
Hello my honey.
Right.
Let me go to show it to people and it just go burr.
I yeah,
I'm trying to learn how to make pizza.
If anybody has a good recipe for a sauce cause that's where it's all about that
in the fucking crust.
All right.
I don't even,
what the fuck I'm talking about anymore?
Let's plow ahead here.
Uh,
what do I have?
What else have I written down here that I want to talk about?
Bombing.
Oh Jesus.
I hate my balls.
Hit the comedy store Saturday night just for like the first like minute and a
half,
cause you know what I was doing,
I was opening with,
okay.
The bit,
that's all my new special that I opened with the fact that I was talking about
wanting to get a gun.
Okay.
So I just Kinda,
you know,
had always been open with that.
And now that my specials out there,
I'm so delusional.
I just automatically assumed that everyone who's ever going to go to a comedy
club,
my dog needs a bath
here.
An itching cleo enough,
come here,
get over here.
So anyways,
I've been,
um,
sorry,
I got to give her the old next scratch here.
Okay.
Hey,
you go,
there you go.
Your mother fucker.
Get out of here.
Um,
yeah,
so have been opening with that.
So then I was like,
well,
it's been on once.
It's on TV,
I can't,
I gotta I gotta dump the joke.
So had this weird thing where I was going out there and I knew everything that I
was going to talk about.
I just didn't know how I was going to open with,
so I was like,
oh,
just fucking,
I dunno.
I wasn't feeling funny.
And it was a,
it was a long,
two,
three minutes before it kind of got it going.
And then I was like,
it just wasn't clicking for me.
Um,
okay.
You know,
something,
it really wasn't even a part of like building a new hour.
It just had to do with the fact that I haven't been on stage for a minute and
it's just like going to the gym.
I was getting winded and might,
Cleo,
are you gonna fucking scratch for the rest of the podcast?
You need a bath,
you know that?
Yeah.
You need a bath.
Go back to sleep.
You were doing great.
She fucking dog.
I swear to God,
this thing,
it's sleeps like 20 hours a day,
you know,
all this shit that they say about pit bulls being vicious and that type of
thing.
I don't know when they do it
all you really have to do,
if you get a dog,
like he's just watch it for that critical four hours when it's awake and you got
it,
you're fine.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's get to a God damn question here.
Advice,
exotic pets.
Uh,
Bill last week I was laid off from my office cubicle job of four years.
I am now a 25 year old unemployed college student.
Trug struggling to make rent.
Ah,
Jesus.
My heart goes out to your brother.
Aleisha 25.
You're not fucking married.
You don't have any kids.
That's the bright side.
And I know you don't need to hear that.
All right.
Here we go.
Can't go back to my parents as they are halfway across the planet and Taiwan.
Now my question is do I continue to,
do I continue trying to get back in the rat race or do I follow my dream of
becoming an exotic pet reptile breeder?
Jesus' crowd,
a fuckboy or you just fucking with me.
This is your dream.
Well,
you know what you are from Taiwan.
I imagine everything that's considered exotic over here is like nothing.
You know,
I bet over in Taiwan,
instead of getting like a bicycle as a four year old,
they give you like a defanged Cobra or some shit.
Um,
I'm sorry,
I just had to stop and laugh at the ignorance of that statement.
Um,
anyways,
I have no experience in the field.
Fantastic.
You're going to be on spike TV's a thousand ways to die except okay.
Except that okay.
I have no experience in the field except for that.
I have a snake in four hamsters as pets.
All right,
dude.
I don't want to burst your bubble,
but there's nothing exotic about hamsters.
Even if you have four or quatro.
Sorry,
I started the new fucking Rosetta stone Spanish again.
Hmm.
You'll Dango on paddle.
It's Greece.
A Blanco.
Beto is Bueno.
Is local a local,
whoever the fuck you say it.
My dogs out of its mind.
Um,
Lamo hair
among sign of their day.
Um,
I've been,
let's get back to this shit.
Like I just said,
the woman and then green apple,
there's really nothing that connected either one of those.
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
I'm going to do it.
At some point in my life I'm going to become bilingual.
So anyways,
it's do wants to start raising exotic pets,
breeding them.
He has no experience.
Now what kind of fucking snake do you have?
You know,
if you have a garden snake gardener,
snake.
I guess you got to start somewhere.
You do have a reptile and a four little rat thinks this is cool,
dude.
You know what you're doing.
You're doing like the open mics of this.
I get it.
You've got to start slow.
You can't start right with the Black Mamba getting,
get yourself killed.
Anyways,
he said,
I've been to the reptile expo a couple of times and saw that vendors,
they're just breed and sell snakes for a living and thought to myself,
Holy Shit,
I want to do that.
Encourage animals to bang and sell the offspring all from my own apartment.
Living the dream.
What to do.
Any advice?
Uh,
what gave you the balls to start stand up?
Um,
understanding the opportunity cost of the income of a full time job.
Uh,
any advice would help.
Thanks Mr. Burn.
All right.
What do you do here?
Well Dude,
you're,
you're doing the right thing.
You basically like you,
you go into one of those a reptile expos and looking at the Douche bags there
when it,
and being like,
I could fucking do that was like me when I used to watch some of those standup
shows and be like,
I'm funnier than this guy.
All right.
And you have the luxury of not having a job right now,
so you don't have to worry about,
you know,
well,
what if this interferes with my job?
You don't have a fucking job.
Um,
your biggest thing right now,
dude,
is you need income.
All right?
So I would continue looking for a job that is flexible.
While you start building your stockpile of reptiles,
first thing I would do is I would go on the Internet and I would read as much as
humanly possible.
I would go to how to make two snakes,
fuck.com I would start,
I don't know what to tell you,
dude.
I would just keep going to those expos like they're open mics.
I would keep reading up on it.
I would try and find,
uh,
this is what you do.
This is what you do.
Act like you want to buy a fucking snake and go to fucking dude
and ask them how they got into the business.
As you pretend like,
you know,
like you're browsing and maybe you can get a job working for one of those guys.
You figured out what the fuck he's doing,
right?
You pull a Joe Kennedy that I've learned reading in the wonderful book the sins
of the father.
Um,
yeah,
that guy used to work every place.
He'd worked at a place for like seven months,
two years.
He'd rifle through all the files,
get all this insider information,
make a boatload of cash and leave the fucking company in the shitter.
Okay?
Now I'm not saying to do that,
but fucking work with,
for these other guys,
figuring out what they're doing,
do what they're doing,
become better at it.
That's what I would do if you really want to do this shit.
I would,
but uh,
I gotta tell you this man,
um,
I don't know how you make two pit vipers fuck each other,
but uh,
I would definitely get a,
uh,
I dunno if I get a thick pair of gloves
hi to reptiles even get turned on.
They just have that fucking look on their face.
Like,
you don't know what they're thinking.
You know,
I'll tell you if snakes had fucking hands,
like they would win world series of poker every year,
there'd be no fucking way to tell what it had said.
Holding shit is he got a full house.
It can't fucking sit there sticking his tongue out at me.
Uh,
should I go bill,
I need your help.
Obviously I must have some real issues to be seeking advice from a standup
comedian,
but here it goes.
You know what,
dude,
that's one of the truest things that's ever been said.
Um,
anyways,
you know something,
I was talking to Bobby Lee this weekend who I'm going to have on the podcast.
I love the guy to death.
And he said a couple of really nice things to me and we were backstage and as I
went to return the compliments,
he literally imploded in,
ran out of the room just at the,
the,
the thought of hearing me say something nice about him.
And I just laughed because he was making a joke about it,
but he was seriously,
he seriously left and slammed the door as I was mid complimenting him and left
me in this room by myself.
And I just laughed out loud to myself and just said,
fucking comedians.
So sir,
you're 100% right to sit there and be to seek advice from a standup comedian.
You gotta be Outta your mind.
But this advice is free.
Here we go.
A couple of years ago,
I decided to travel the world.
He says,
due to boredom,
or she says,
who the fuck knows?
Uh,
due to Borden and just a general feeling of unhappiness,
God's a good thing to do.
I needed to get away.
Everything went great from there.
I met so many good people,
enjoyed my time and other countries and ended up feeling so much better in the
end.
Uh,
yeah,
dude,
you had an adventure.
I said,
I recently decided to go home for a visit before continuing on and it ended up
in a disaster.
Oh,
so you were still traveling world and decided to go
home or you were back in the states and decided to go to your hometown?
I don't know.
Either way.
You went home from wherever the hell you were at.
Uh,
my parents were fighting.
Most of my friends had either changed or left and it turned out to be a real
shitty time for me.
The question is,
am I wrong to want to travel still,
I am leaving again straight away and most people I know are making me feel
terrible that I want to leave.
It's nothing personal.
I just don't feel happy here and I really missed the friends that I made and
other places.
Should I make the people feel bad or is it time to tell them to suck a big fat
one?
Yeah.
Oh,
should I let people make me feel bad or is it time to tell them to suck the big
fat one?
Ah,
dude,
you're following your heart.
It's a great story.
You should go for it.
And you learned the awful lesson that everybody has to learn is that you can
never go home.
Okay.
Because people move on,
people change.
You walk into that bar and you're not going to see anybody that you know
anymore.
And if you do,
they're going to be a lot fatter and a lot sadder.
Something awful is going to happen.
You know,
they ruptured this spleen.
You just don't want to do it.
You just don't want to do it,
you know?
Okay.
So go live your life.
The reason why you feel happy when you're out there traveling,
I feel is cause you following your heart.
You listening to that voice that's telling you what to do.
You go back to that town.
Everybody's negative.
People are fighting course.
They don't want you to leave.
They don't want you to make something yourself.
Cause it's still sitting there sipping on a fucking Milla.
So yeah,
you don't have to tell him to suck a big fat one.
You just see like,
you know,
this is what I want to do,
and then just send them cards from all over the world and then I'll make him
even more angry as they sit there watching you get blown in Venice,
I one of those fucking boats with that dude and the stripe shirt,
he's not blowing you.
Of course.
It's some other chick with a mole right above her lip and he sitting there
singing a song,
try and drown out the side of her sucking your Dick.
That's basically how it goes down.
Is that a good picture?
You know?
Okay,
Hey,
you know what?
Why don't you fucking go travel,
go buy some exotic snakes and sell them to that other dude is trying to sell is
to start his business.
Then you take the money that you made,
right,
and you fucking use that to travel more.
See that connecting via the podcast.
All right,
we got a fat fuck redemption.
We got a redemption here.
This is a nice shout out to Wa tosh point.
Oh,
this guy's obviously a touch point.
Oh Fan.
I'm not trying to steal anything from that show fat fuck redemption bill.
I'm a 35 year old guy and I've been a big fat fuck for most of my life.
Well,
you know what sir?
The first step is admitting it.
The fact that you can call yourself a big fat fuck.
You know,
like me,
when I go through my periods,
when I know I need to quit drinking,
it's what I say to myself.
Oh,
Billy fat again,
big fucking stupid.
Fucking a head full of booze,
big John Travolta.
Fucking head loser.
Stop your drinking.
That's what I do.
Or else I won't listen to myself.
Is this podcast going off the rails?
I feel like I can't even think right now.
Um,
anyways,
I developed an amazing set of breasts.
It's tender age of 13.
All right.
This is a guy who had just had a look at the name,
uh,
that still puts both of my sisters racks to shame.
Four to 20 pounds was my heaviest by ml.
So six foot seven and bill white and built like the Iris Sasquatch.
So I carry it pretty well.
You see what I'm saying?
This is why this guy is so funny.
He had equal tits at 13.
He's six foot seven.
He's 420 pounds.
There's no way to not look like that and not be a funny motherfucker.
I'm about 10 years ago,
I dropped 150 pounds through,
uh,
through diet and exercise.
I had a whole new life,
new career,
beautiful women,
the whole Shebang.
I had a a good seven year run.
Yeah,
dude,
that's great man.
Seven years.
You're funny motherfucker.
You're six foot seven.
They probably feel like they're being held by a big bear.
You make them feel safe.
The next thing you know the fucker.
Yeah,
I totally see it.
Totally see it.
So anyways,
he said,
so here's my dilemma.
About three years ago,
I got off the track and put a lot of the weight back on and haven't had a
girlfriend the whole time.
Mostly by choice.
Ah,
you went to some self-loathing thing back in the groove.
Now dropping the weight and getting healthy again.
I want to settle down and start something serious with the woman of my dreams.
But I still have about 50,
60 pounds to work off.
In a perfect world,
it would be all about inner beauty and personality and shit.
But let's be realistic.
A smart,
talented,
good looking health conscious woman is just not going to settle for a dude who
was swinging around bigger tits than her.
Huh?
You know what,
dude?
Personality goes a long way,
but you're,
you're 100% right when you're talking about the man tits,
you got to get rid of him.
He says,
I suck at casual dating and I tend to get sucked into longterm relationships
very easily.
Uh,
so my question is,
do I wait till I'm in the prime shape again before I start getting serious with
anyone?
Uh,
I'm not trying to be perfect,
but I'm not looking for perfection,
but I just want to be smart about it.
What do you think about the brick top?
Um,
all right.
You have to learn how to not only are you losing weight,
but you got,
you got to learn how to date,
dude.
All right.
You've addressed that you're a fat fuck and you're dealing with that.
You also got address that you're,
uh,
you're codependent and you're fucking lonely.
All right?
And it sucks if you codependent,
you're a relationship guy,
so it's very easy for you to get sucked into relationships.
But
you know,
you can't take the first and it comes down the pike.
Uh,
okay.
So what you,
you,
you listen to deal.
You so know that you get sucked into relationship.
This is what I think that you're like,
all right.
So if I'm going to get sucked into a relationship,
I have to look the best that I can possibly look.
So when I do get sucked into a relationship,
I got a fucking,
you know,
top shelf girl that I'm doing it with.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I don't think that that's going to work.
Personally.
I think you need to learn how to date.
Just go out and start dating
and,
and I,
and why don't you say that?
I would say that on the date.
So where's this going?
Uh,
just be like,
you know what,
I'm in a period of my life,
what I'm trying to learn how to date.
What does,
what does that mean?
It means that I'm one of those.
I'm a relationship guy and I tend to get sucked into relationships.
And,
uh,
next thing you know,
I'm in a relationship with someone I should have just had one or two dates with.
So,
you know,
I'm not trying to be a,
I'm just being upfront.
That's where I'm at right now.
So,
uh,
I have a list of questions and judging by your answers,
will depend with,
there's going to be date number two.
You don't have to say that last part,
but uh,
definitely you gotta you gotta you gotta come at it that way,
man.
Just come right out of the gate like that.
You know something,
you'll get some fucking ass.
Even with your God damn tits talking like that.
You walk into a bar,
right?
You sit there,
you already got a sense of humor.
You make them fucking laugh.
Some girls eventually gonna come walking up to you some mess or maybe some
fucking borderline QT.
They're insecure to,
you know,
maybe they don't like their fucking ass.
Who knows what,
right?
They come walking up to you as to what's your deal?
What are you doing?
Just sitting there,
you know,
and he'd just start talking about there's nothing to fucking broad likes better
than some fucking guy who was sitting there who's actually taken stock in
himself,
who seems like he's going to start taking life seriously.
Okay.
Cause they look at us and they see us for the morons that we are led by our
dicks playing in mud,
puddles breaking shit,
acting like a bunch of fucking gorillas.
So when they see somebody who's actually sitting there contemplating,
but where the fuck that go on in life and what they want,
they're attracted to it.
Not to mention you six foot seven,
they're going to feel safe and then they gotta be wondering,
well,
is this deck five foot seven?
Right?
So he just hit him with that line.
What are you doing?
I'm trying to figure life up.
I have to learn how to date and there'll be all over it.
What do you mean daddy's easy?
You should have by an ex,
you know,
are fucking hands on your thigh,
right?
Couple of limes in the coronas and exceeding or whatever.
Alright.
Hey,
that's,
that's what,
that's what I hope happens for you.
All right,
the last one here before I wrap up the podcast.
So do I have any other fucking average,
let me,
let's,
let's fucking try to,
I know you guys don't like listening to all these fucking ads,
but I got to do,
I'm here.
All right.
amazon.com would you like to fucking support this podcast and the wounded
warriors project wealth?
This is all you got to do.
Go to bill bird.com.
Click on the podcast page and then click on the banner ad,
the Amazon Banner Ad.
It'll take you right to Amazon.
You don't have to do anything like that.
Go on there.
Go Buy yourself a drum stool or a fucking ladle,
whatever you want to do.
Amazon kicks me a percentage of whatever you spent,
and then I take 10% basically of all the advertising that I have on this,
and I kick it over to the wounded warriors project.
So you'd be helps support in this project and the troops.
All right.
Can you get any better than that?
I don't think he can,
but I'll tell you what's a close second game?
fly.com.
Oh,
what a segue professional.
Um,
basically go to the banner ad once again on Bill bird.com and the podcast page
and you click on the banner for your free to disk two week free trial,
$23 value over 40 people did that last month.
So thank you very much for that.
And hopefully you will enjoy the service.
If you want a free two week trial,
go to www.game fly.com/burr or their banner on my podcast page for your free
trial and enjoy all the video games.
You can play 8,000 video games a free two week trial.
You're Outta your mind.
Go buy a big bag of Doritos and a 12 pack of your favorite soda cause you got
8,000 games to play.
Mr Or ma'am,
is there anything hotter than a fucking chick that likes to play video games?
You know,
like,
like those violent ones?
I don't even know what they're called anymore.
I had to wean myself off of them.
Pay Low and that type of stuff.
I Dunno.
I think it's cool.
All right,
the last one here.
I don't even know what this one's true guys.
I hope this is true.
I don't know that,
but this,
this,
this seems too true too.
I mean,
too unbelievable to be true.
This is called threesome says,
dear bill,
I was a virgin who never wrote in,
but listen to your,
listen to you respond to other virgins who wrote in I am 19 not exactly old,
but who wants to break 20 before blowing your load and age girl.
The remarkable part,
um,
is that I had a threesome to kick off my new life as not a virgin.
See that?
This guy's trying to make me believe that right out of the gate.
I mean,
it can happen.
People get called up from the minors their first fucking time.
You know,
they hit for the fucking cycle.
They throw a perfect game.
It can happen,
but I'm reading this one with a grain of salt.
I don't know if this is a listener fucking with me or what,
but here we go.
He said,
I met this girl.
Let's see.
I'll believable if sound's all right,
then we'll take a vote whether you believe this or not.
I hope it's true.
Anyways,
I met this girl at the beach
last summer and ran into her again sometime in July.
She's being very flirty and kept talking about her summer bucket list.
She said her and her friend had the same goal.
I thought they meant that they separately wanted to get the flowered.
Not Thinking that hey,
everyone is probably not thinking that hey,
everyone is probably getting laid.
I figured we were all on the same page.
Oh,
so you thought that they were both versions.
So week back I invited to a party.
My friend was having,
she brings her friend and her friend is hotter.
Uh,
I start working on her cause I'm drunk and on a roll and I'm going for broke.
Good for you,
good for you.
And in fact,
at one point another dude came in to interrupt the conversation and I gave him
a,
Whoa,
you got to,
you got to raise your hand.
What does that mean?
He raised it all.
I'll you got to raise your hand to come into the conversation.
Jesus Christ,
this kid took his Fonzie pills.
I said,
he uh,
he raised his hand and I called him a clown.
Everyone laughed.
What a fucking idiot.
He did that anyways,
why wouldn't I think this girl want,
wanted to bang.
Wait a minute,
dude.
How are you?
This fucking cool.
And you never got any ass before.
This doesn't make any sense.
You're coming off like a Billy Ray Valentine here anyways.
Well,
it turns out her and her friends wanted to have a threesome.
I realized this when they both told me flat out that they want it to,
I went for a bill.
I didn't really know what I was doing for the first 10 seconds or so.
But after that,
it just all made sense.
Like when Neil saw the matrix,
I couldn't have done it without the podcast.
Well,
let me ask you this.
Do you guys believe that?
I didn't know what I was doing for the first 10 seconds.
And then you all of a sudden you understood,
but then he makes a reference to neo in the Matrix,
which is something that a fucking nerd would do.
I Dunno.
It's a hell of a story.
I hope it's true.
They did.
That just doesn't make sense.
You're fucking virgin.
You get a threesome the first time without paying for it.
You know,
you fucking,
you have the ball,
you're a fucking virgin.
But you had the bitch.
You're making the move of a guy who has gotten laid where you go for the even
harder one and then you stop the guy from cock blocking you.
You know,
I mean it,
unless you're an absolute,
you're fucking the natural.
There's no way.
How do you have all these skills?
He never got laid before.
I'm calling bullshit on this one.
I hope it's true.
I really do.
And if it is true,
I want to know what the fuck you would drink it.
Um,
our right.
Is that the podcast?
I don't know if it is way,
way,
way wait.
stamps.com I forgot.
stamps.com everybody stamps.com if you like to stop going to the post office,
I want to be great.
If you could stop going there yet.
Be able to do everything that you could do at the post office,
within your own place of where you live.
Print stamps,
have your own scale,
weigh packages,
be able to run off little metered,
the whatever the hell a box cause.
Sorry I don't have the copy.
I think I have it memorized at this point.
Go to stamps.com/bird type in [inaudible] for your free two week trial of
stamps.com
you know the deal.
You guys listened to this stuff every week.
You don't have to go to the post office anymore.
He just go to stamps.com you get,
you can print out legal postage.
You get your own scale.
It's wonderful.
I send out all my DVDs that whole month of touring that I have.
I'm not going to the post office month.
I'm going to once,
I'm going to send out all of my DVDs using stamps.com.
All right,
so there you go.
That is the podcast for this week.
Thank you guys so much for listening.
Thank you guys for,
uh,
going to Amazon,
helping me,
uh,
you know,
and actually,
helping out the wounded warriors project.
It's a,
it's one of the few like wholesome things that I do in my life.
So that's it.
Is that how we're going to go out?
Do I not have anything else to talk about?
I'm going to end on a damn commercial.
Why did say thank you?
I am over the hour.
I've done my God damn time here.
All my batteries down to one little cell there.
All right,
so it's going to wipe out anyways.
so that's it.
Please come out and see me in Orlando,
Florida,
Charlotte,
North Carolina,
New York City,
Jacksonville,
Florida,
Cincinnati,
Sydney,
Australia.
I'm going to be on the night of too many stars in New York City and uh,
what else do,
I don't know what else I got coming up.
That's going to be me the next six weeks,
east banner and Dan loaded up and trucking.
I'm going to all the white trash fucking cities.
So bring your tattoo titties and your stupid fucking boyfriend pulled up in your
truck with the steel nuts hanging off the back.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.